I mean I'm I'm all obviously for
hammering the cultural issues and I
think it has helped in the race but they
also failed on the economic questions
because there was a big split coming out
of democrat leadership on the rare
occasions they did talk about the
economy which was the number one issue
for most people and Joe Biden's answer
the White House line was the economy is
great what are you talking about we're
not in a recession everything's
wonderful you saved 16 cents on hot dogs
right so that was his line and then the
line coming out of the D Triple C which
we just heard two days ago this is the
Democrat Congressional Campaign
Committee run by Sean Patrick Maloney
who very possibly could lose his seat
tonight is oh families are struggling
and they can't afford groceries just by
by Chef Boyardee buy some cheap hand
pasta soup and and then you'll save
money and both of those lines well for
starters they're contradictory right
it's not happening and it's good that it
is but the the other thing is it is so
callous it is so disconnected from the
reality